a ukrainian official says that russian
shelling has killed another two people
in ukraine's second largest city kharkiv
another 19 are injured including a child
elsewhere ukraine's military is training
its soldiers to use new weapons arriving
from the west
keeve hopes that the new anti-tank
rocket launchers and mortars will change
the tide of the war
earlier washington announced it was also
sending more longer-range arms to
ukraine russia has criticized the u.s
saying the move forces moscow to widen
the conflict in ukraine
as the west pass more and more
long-range weapons such as highmars into
ukraine in an impotent rage
or in a desire to exacerbate the
situation as much as possible
that means the geographical tasks of the
special operation will extend still
further from the current line
we cannot allow the parts of ukraine
that president vladimir lenski
or whoever replaces him will control
to have weapons that will pose a direct
threat to our territory
and the territory of those republics
that have declared their independence
[Music]
earlier i spoke with dw correspondent
matthias bolinger in kiev he told us how
ukrainians are reacting to lavrov's
announcement of extending russian war
goals
let's just put this a little bit into
perspective russia has in february
attacked from three sides including the
capital of kiev and uh vladimir putin
has uh has heard a speech where he
basically denied the existence of
ukraine as a nation so here in ukraine
nobody ever believed that these military
actions will be limited to the donbass
other than for short
strategic adjustments russia was not
able to advance further
in the north and uh it has been stopped
in the south before entering the collide
and uh then for the odessa which are the
most two most important port cities so
um
if
lavrov now blames the west uh to uh for
for for expanding its military goals
that's of course a propaganda coup that
nobody here in ukraine falls for because
uh this um is something that russia has
often done it has often blamed its own
um or framed its own ambitions as a
reaction to the west uh so here in
ukraine there hasn't been much of a
reaction to lavrov's words because they
are nothing new basically and the eu
just imposed new sanctions on russia but
ukraine's president zielenski said last
night that that's not enough what does
he want
well
he's always asking for the maximum of
course that's a
reasonable thing to do for somebody who
is in that position
and that would be to cut russia off any
income by from gas and oil or
or nearly cut them off and he's been
talking a lot of course about that two
north stream pipelines one of which has
never been operating which was which was
suspended due to the war and the other
one um which has been operating already
quite a few years north stream one which
is going um
which is delivering gas from today on
again so um the the aim of ukraine is of
course to weaken the income of russia so
russia cannot finance its war any
further
meantime what's the latest on the ground
matthias
well um we've seen heavy fighting we've
seen shelling we've just seen the
pictures in the eastern regions in the
past few days there was also quite some
activity in the south mainly rocket
attacks on odessa and cluster ammunition
and rockets on mikolief
which also speaks to the claim that
russia is making to the south
what ukraine has done uh is to intensify
its attacks on the hassan region and it
seems to have hit the most important
bridge there hairson is on the north
side of the nepa river and supplies from
russia are coming in from the south from
crimea and there are very few bridges
across the niapa river one is this
antonov bridge that has been hit by the
ukrainians so they're targeting uh now
the supply lines of the russians in
order to
launch their counter-offensive
matthias bolinger and kiev thank you